the first two installments of the disney
plus original series one division wowed
fans and critics alike adding yet
another win to the marvel cinematic
universe's track record
episode 3 was another mind-bending
chapter that may have left you
scratching your head
here's what went down despite only
realizing her pregnancy at the end of
one division's second episode
wanda's pregnancy begins moving at a
breakneck pace she goes from being four
months along only to jump ahead to six
before having to give birth on her
living room floor mere moments later
it was there behind their avocado green
70s couch that she envisioned met their
twins billy and tommy for the first time
this moment should come as no surprise
to fans of wanda and vision from the
pages of marvel comics
additionally their birth could
potentially point to one of their
greatest foes coming to live
action very soon on the page the couple
have twins of the same names who later
grow up to become the heroes speed and
wiccan but not before disappearing from
existence entirely
to create their kids with intact souls
wanda accidentally stole some of the
demon mephisto's life essence
the villain eventually took it back
resulting in him wiping the twins from
the face of the earth
the devil's in the details bev that's
not the only place he is
whether or not this is the direction
marvel studios would take these future
young avengers members remains to be
seen
surely subsequent one division
installments will elaborate on their
role in the story
in the same vein as the stark industries
toaster and the strucker watch from the
first two wandavision installments
episode 3 delivers on yet another cheeky
reference to the mcu via classic
commercial and a very clear nod to the
popular calgon bath power commercials
from the 70s
viewers are greeted by an advertisement
for hydra soap a fictional bath powder
that will help users find the goddess
within
also the cutaway mentions that the
product is great for those who want to
get away without actually going anywhere
sure it may sound like just a cheesy
tagline but it could have some sinister
implications
when looking at the mcu in its entirety
hydra is a persistent evil
they were at the height of their power
during the world war ii based captain
america the first avenger and remained a
background threat into the modern day
until avengers age of ultron
the avengers were working on mopping up
the remaining cells of the faction in
the 2015 film
in the process they also uncovered a set
of twins who had been tested on and
thanks to the mind stone granted
superhuman abilities
wanda and pietro maximoff what exactly
these commercial breaks mean in each
wand division episode remains a mystery
in universe or otherwise even still
their ties to the canon itself cannot be
understated
especially regarding wanda she blamed
tony stark in his weapons company stark
industries for the death of her parents
later baron wolfgang von strucker's
experiments led to her and pietro
gaining their powers
and hydro was the organization that made
it happen this raises the question
could hydra be the ones helping wanda
get away to wherever she is without
really going anywhere
or much like stark and strucker is the
mention of hydra merely a nod to her
origins
we'll just have to wait and see much
like its predecessors this one division
episode centers primarily on the titular
couple
however a few other characters make the
odd appearance throughout
chief among them is wanda's friend
geraldine who helps her through the
difficult birth of her first child
she may seem innocent and kind-hearted
on the outside but it appears as though
there's more to her story than meets the
eye
both agnes and herb note that geraldine
recently popped up in their town without
a family connections or even a home to
speak of
meanwhile wanda tells geraldine about
her late twin brother piertro
in response geraldine mentions his
demise at the hands of ultron
leading wanda to lose her cool and
interrogate her supposed friend about
who she is and how she knows so much
her suspicions only increase as she
notices the mysterious pendant around
her neck that bears resemblance to the
sword emblem we saw in the first two
episodes
ultimately wanda uses her powers to kick
geraldine out of her world
giving the audience the clearest glimpse
of the world outside of west view yet
meanwhile according to previous casting
announcements tiona paris didn't sign on
to wand division to portray an
inquisitive neighbor named geraldine
rather she's actually on the cast list
as monica rambo who debuted in 2019's 90
set captain marvel as the child of pilot
maria rambo
your mom's lucky when they were handing
out kids they gave her the toughest one
lieutenant trouble you remembered
it appears she's an agent of sword and
has some vested interest in bringing
wanda out of her tbs
new life if this episode was any
indication her role in wandavision can
only expand from here
as the cracks in this false reality
continue to spread
just before the credits begin to roll
the show's third episode offers up a bit
of insight as to where wanda and vision
really are
after blowing her cover monica rambo is
launched out of wanda's reality landing
in what appears to be an empty grassy
field
in no time at all military vehicles
helicopters and armored personnel arrive
on the scene
as the camera pans away we see a few
structures that resemble barracks and a
line of light similar to those found in
a sports arena across some kind of force
field
though this still leaves more questions
than answers it's finally revealed that
wanda and vision's lovely home in west
view isn't what they think it is
not only is it not a physical town but
it also appears to be either a
projection or some kind of bubble with
the presentation of a typical suburb
inside of it
as far as its occupants go one has to
wonder if they're aware of the town's
unreality
or if they're even real living people in
the first place after all agnes and
herb's admissions about their suspicions
of geraldine shows there's more to them
than they're letting on
the matter of who's creating this pocket
dimension and why as well as the status
of those within it
is certainly a point to ponder in the
coming weeks as wandavision's mysteries
start getting revealed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]